[Music]
ever wonder why laramie from yellowstone
looks so familiar well for one you may
have seen her on a popular tv comedy
about a fire department in one of the
country's rainiest cities which show is
it keep watching to find out yellowstone
premiered in 2018 and has since gone on
to earn critical acclaim and several
western heritage awards taking place in
beautiful montana the series is a breath
of fresh air with a side of cowboys in
the show's third season several
newcomers are introduced to the ranch
the majority of them being strong women
for example laramie played by hassie
harrison a barrel racer and the best
friend of fellow barrel racer mia makes
her entrance on yellowstone in episode 5
of season 3.
barrel races are a bit like rock stars
where you know they're just trying to
have a laugh and a good time
she brings with her a whole lot of
ruckus and drama that shake things up on
the show the addition of laramie to the
yellowstone dunton ranch bunkhouse
breaks the rule of no women in the
bunkhouse and it's soon clear why it's
not long before the yellowstone charmer
gets caught up in a love triangle that
causes a rift between two of the ranch
hands lloyd pierce and walker laramie's
personality might be unlike any other
but harrison herself is a familiar face
here are a few more of harrison's film
and tv roles from before her breakout
performance on yellowstone the cw's
romantic drama heart of dixie is about
dr zoe hart an aspiring heart surgeon
who is looking to follow in her father's
footsteps and takes up a medical
residency in blue bell alabama in a few
episodes throughout season three and
four viewers can catch a glimpse of
hassie harrison as lucy who is wade
kinsella's girlfriend playing lucy on
heart of dixie is harrison's first major
television acting role since then
harrison has been seen in a variety of
projects including dementia as shelby
lockhart southbound as gem and max
reload and the nether blasters as the
character liz one other project that may
be familiar to yellowstone viewers is
the iron orchard based on the novel by
tom pendleton the iron orchard is a film
set amongst the oil fields in a world
war ii era texas hassi harrison plays
the lovely mazie wales the sweet love
interest of the movie's protagonist jim
mcneely mcneely sets out to the oil
fields in the hopes of hitting it big
but he soon learns that working in the
fields of texas is tough work and
fortunes don't happen overnight true to
form harrison's character fits the
glamorous vibrant lipstick style of the
times with a texas-sized personality
ultimately she's the driving force that
motivates mcnealy to make a name for
himself the movie's imdb rating sits at
a mid-level 5.8 out of 10 which means
that it was a bit of a mixed bag for
viewers nevertheless it's only more
proof that if there's one role harrison
has perfected it's that of a country gal
yellowstone isn't harrison's only
experience working as part of the main
cast of a television show although
tacoma fd is a bit more comedic than the
western themed drama yellowstone viewers
might be used to hassie harrison is seen
as lucy a fun-loving upbeat young
addition to the fire department lucy is
the daughter of the fire department
chief terry who isn't sure about her
joining the crew but she soon proves him
wrong so if you're all caught up on
yellowstone and looking to see more of
harrison but maybe less of laramie check
out any of these performances
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one